hey guys it's Justine I'm currently in
Hawaii and I just got my hands on the
new samsung galaxy s 20 this is the pink
version you guys know when I was at the
event and I saw that they announced this
I was honestly freaking out because the
color of it is just so incredible know
you've seen it already but now it's here
in person in my hands I just can't
believe it it looks really really good
obviously I liked a couple of corteguay
outfits for the phone that on the boxing
so at this point you've seen everyone
unbox a bunch of Samsung phones this is
the s20 there's two other versions
there's the s20 plus and the s20 ultra
which is the highest end line on phone
booth Samsung currently has and I'll
tell you what the thing looks really
great I still just wish that iPhone came
in pink I mean really you guys should
think about it so this model starts at
$9.99 it has it the same triple camera
setup as the others but it is lacking
the depth vision camera got a 10
megapixel selfie camera 12 megapixel
ultra wide 12 megapixel wide-angle and a
64 megapixel telephoto it also does ap
video it has a smaller 6.2 inch AMOLED
display and it's cool because all three
of these new models of phones do have
120 Hertz display if you've never really
seen 130 Hertz screen before I recommend
you go to a store that has these I know
Best Buy has them just go check it out
just look how incredible it looks I
definitely have my fingers crossed that
Apple will be integrating 120 Hertz
screen this year I feel like that's
gonna be a pretty common standard in
most phones going forward this also has
eight case shooting capabilities which
is really it's kind of crazy just to
think about being able to have something
in your pocket that does shoot 8k the
only thing that I've seen from some
people who have done reviews already and
then have shown some test footage is the
8k crops I think for most people that
are getting these phones I don't really
think that they're even going to be
shooting in 8k you can choose to shoot
however high of the quality that you
want and of course we do shoot something
in 8k you can downgrade it to 4k there
are onboard editing apps which make that
super simple so that does bring up a
point of storage if you are shooting a
lot of vacant content it will eat up
your storage a little bit faster but you
can't expand this storage up to one
terabyte with a micro SD card as 128
gigs internal storage so gigs of RAM and
1/4
milliamp battery so normally I have my
iPhone and then I have a secondary
Android device and usually whatever the
newest one is at the time that I'm
testing me out that's what it is and I
have had my secondary phone as the
Samsung galaxys you flip recently I did
plan on making a follow-up video to this
thing and for some reason I never got
around to doing it yet I haven't super
busy and traveling but it's been very
interesting to see the reaction that
this phone has had with people as I'm
visiting my parents and my dad we were
sitting at dinner and he was on his
phone just reading about the latest news
and this was maybe like 2 or 3 days
after this phone was released he's like
did you guys hear about this folding
phone and I'm sitting there
this phone is sitting right next to my
plate and he had no idea at all I was
like oh and I just handed it over to him
I was like hmm it is a cool phone it's
great I don't even know what else to say
about it because this videos supposed to
be about this little guy I think Samsung
did a really great job with this book so
it's just these guys the thumbs up let's
see what else is in the box
Oh charging brick AKG headphones Oh USB
see what's this nothing trash I totally
missed the case for the flip phone when
I first in box it I'm gonna go get this
charged and set up and I'll take it out
for a spin I gotta be very careful I
could not be trusted I just finished my
unboxing and now we're gonna head to
dinner and then we're gonna go for a
little walk like I said before we're in
Oahu this is one my favorite islands in
Hawaii it's just beyond beautiful so
it's kind of unfair when you bring me a
smartphone here to do camera tests
because everything looks
but first dinner
I don't know um testing Wow John did
Park very close to his car yeah maybe
you should just move over you move over
yep denna just told me to not take a
selfie in the middle of the road cuz I'm
gonna get squished
do they know that I'm doing a full
review probably not I feel a little rain
sprinkle we've got our wide angle 1x 3x
it's really cool about some of these
earphones is there obviously enhancing
in the zoom lens the s20 ultra has 100 X
zoom he looks a little gimmicky because
obviously the high-tech zoom does not
look that incredible but the fact you
can do 100x zoom on a cell phone and
still be able to actually make out what
if taking a picture is still pretty cool
so the s20 it has a 30x zoom so let's
take a few photos and let's see what
that looks like
[Music]
I went through all of the zooms and 30x
looks pretty cool it's kind of crazy cuz
look how far away that building is I
mean it's all the way over there time to
eat some of my favorite restaurants
there's a few of them on the islands
I've actually never been to this current
location hey let's do it it's just so
here's my salad I got the fish salad so
it's basically a salad with fish it's a
salad with fish
[Music]
it's raining few drops by assad's to Jos
earners a suburb is gonna go for a walk
yeah okay the Sun is setting
[Music]
no it has started raining we're gonna
miss the sunset it's currently setting
right now let's go let's go let's go
Jenna shattered her iPhone here last
year she just got it it slid all the way
down here whose sole drama
[Music]
look at Jenna over there it is raining
very hard we probably should
there's the sunset through the trees I
guess we're gonna go down I think it's
raining pretty hard the sunset is so
pretty though oh there we go there's the
other side I don't need it
got a poncho now
[Music]
so for ya still writing yeah dad you
want my Posse back okay I don't know if
this is helping you're making it worse
because now the water has run down all
of my entire body that was on the back
[Music]
I guess that concludes my samsung s 20
vlog we have run out of light which
means the vlog is over heading home to
edit see you guys later
I look forward to I have a couple other
fun tech things unbox to say we'll look
for those soon also go follow me on tic
toc because I'm obsessed
find me on Instagram Twitter don't
forget to subscribe like comment and do
all of the things the aback